[Music]
my love of kites started about 20 years
ago I taught math to 35 years I just
combine the two to try to reach all of
my students I figured why not take this
whole math lesson outside maybe just
maybe they would see the relationship
[Music]
my name is Winfred randolph law but in
delray on the beach when I'm flying my
tights they call me Randy the kite man I
[Music]
started flying kite 20 years ago I
bought my first crab and I never look
back I fly my cards as much as possible
I have about 60 or 70 carries on any
particular given day you can paint the
sky with sea creatures whales scuba
divers you're not only looking at the
kite but you're looking at the strings
there's math there then you can do
something with it
cakes are geometric figures kites are
triangles and that is one of the things
that I tried to take advantage of
instead of doing it in a classroom your
desk would take on the field Pythagorean
theorem is a formula used to determine
sides of triangles if you want to use
that in theorem on the beach as we're
trying to fly a kite and let the kite go
and it travels up the line better known
as the hypotenuse if we draw a line from
the top of the cake down to the bottom
that's side a if we draw another line
from that point back to where we let the
kid go that would be side B so by
plugging those numbers into the triangle
we have just figured out how long I'll
string this and where we are standing to
the top of the kind
patience we could be fractions common
denominator
uncommon to them more complicated the
numbers are the more math there is I
retired six years ago we get a lot of
families to come on Delray Beach and
they have kids and I teach math I don't
see that right there we could do a math
problem like that you know and some kids
understand oh yeah we did that in school
nowadays they see it but for the lot of
the younger kids get some thinking to
[Music]
[Music]
the ice is typically around five
centimeters when I skate on that sound
you hear is actually a combination of
two sound it's their sounds from cracks
striking beneath me and the vibrations
within the ice plate itself it sounds
like it's something supersonic meet
Morten Einar hi I'm Morten ina he's a
mathematician who enjoys riskier hobbies
than most I've been skating on thin ice
for 40 years when he's skating though
he's also listening consider the ice the
higher the pitch just about when the ice
is to break and that would be about
three centimeters the pitch is at the
highest see they're supposedly highest
note for the soprano see wooden relies
on his knowledge as a mathematician to
calculate the thickness of the ice it's
flexibility and it's temperature many
people tend to freak out when they see a
skating on thin ice but I couldn't be
more calm because I know what I'm doing
sometimes the ice is perfectly clear and
I can see fish blow even a beaver and
also free divers swimming under the eyes
when Morten first started there wasn't
any physics or scientific information to
explain how thin ice skating is possible
he studied the ice for ten years every
winter to explain the phenomenon
I observed three things with a thin ice
one is that the ice bends and the
thinner it is the more advanced the arms
needs to be flexible to support you
second the first crack is a true warning
signals then I know the ice is thin and
when it gets even thinner more
first of all finally the ice gives
sonorous tone beautiful eerie tone which
immediately tells me how thick the ice
is
it's called the coincidence frequency
and it can be calculated mathematically
Gordon has skated on over 1,800 bodies
of water in North America Norway and
Central and Eastern Europe I love
skating for the excitement and
challenges it brings it's an opportunity
for master nature to come together and
make it understandable for me I've been
skating most of my life and I always
look forward to next week
[Music]
we don't go ahead and get situated this
is the finance program and we always
like to see new faces when you come to
Wall Street financial literacy class
you're gonna see people with tattoos and
dreads and just people you normally
wouldn't expect to see learn and finance
you're gonna see people of all different
backgrounds looking for hope he makes it
universal if I tell you I'll give you
250 bucks but I want you to pay me back
50 dollars in interest what you're gonna
say you're gonna say what and why you're
gonna say no they called me Wall Street
because I teach all the financial
classes here at San Quentin and I've
been teaching financial education for
about 10 years now I am in prison for
participating in a robbery murder and I
was sentenced to 54 years to life in
prison for that crime
and I've been incarcerated now for 22
years these are the stocks that I picked
the MasterCard
I got 89 they're at 200 Wall Street came
to prison they illiterate he doesn't
have a college education to this day he
just only has a GED and yet this guy is
successfully trading from prison my
cellie who had come from juvenile hall
with me he would read the sports page to
me but I mean go get it and I read it I
grabbed the paper and I was like I got
it
when I turned around on order guy said
hey man you play the stock market and
I've realized that I picked up the
business section instead of sports page
I was like God man and I asked him what
the stock market was and he told me he
said that's the place where white folks
keep all their money and and that's when
I really first discovered the stock
market so I started to teach myself how
to read family friends on the outside
opened up online brokers accounts and I
basically told him what the buying when
to buy and when to sell and I mean I was
just simply Brazil was really just that
easy
this is a finance program but I don't
teach about finance
I teach financial empowerment emotional
literacy that's what I teach so I think
financial education is important for car
serated people giving it the crimes that
are committed are financially motivated
and driven when I learned about
financial education myself um I thought
that would be something that other men
and my same situation could benefit from
and so now the program teaches
incarcerated men how to better manage
their emotions and relations to their
financial standing so you gotta weigh
your strategies when you're talking
about giving you some room to start
saving money when you're traumatized you
do a lot of things you don't know why
you're doing them and that happens with
finance - I suffered a lot of trauma in
my life and my trauma like culminated in
me murdering a man so while this is very
important to me because I do need to
manage my money and manage my life
what's most important is that I'm
managing my emotional responsibilities
because the last time I didn't do that a
man lost his life I don't think you can
have full rehabilitation without
financial education I can make amends
for the crimes that I've done I can even
stop doing the things that I've done but
I think for people who were criminals
when you empower those people and they
know that they don't have to commit a
crime like I did when I learned that I
have to commit crime it was like wow
like I can really make some of my life
and I have to be a criminal
[Music]
[Music]
the legend around this chalk is that
it's impossible to write a false theorem
I assume the special ingredients as
angel tears mathematicians from all the
top schools very frequently is it it's a
cult favorite as soon as I use it I want
to convert the chalk is one of the
best-kept secrets in the math world it's
the rolls-royce of truck hog Oromo is a
brand of Japanese chalk the way it flows
on a board is a bit hard to describe in
words it's really hard to get only get
it from Japan you need a Japanese person
to bring it back for you I discovered it
when I went to visit the University of
Tokyo and one of the professor's there
said to me you know we have better chalk
than you do in the States and I said oh
go on chalk his chalk and so I tried it
out and I was surprised to find that he
was right I tried it I thought was
phenomenal it's the densest it erases
the cleanest that leaves the nicest line
if you use bad chalk often you're
depressed really hard for anyone to see
what you're writing
so using hagoromo on a good board it
doesn't really feel like you're working
hard to write when I'm teaching I get a
feeling of energy confidence and the
chalk absolutely helps slowly the math
world has become aware of this and it
became a bit of a fad in some circles
it was like maybe four years ago the
word came out that the company was going
out of business
I sort of jokingly referred to it as a
chalk apocalypse so I immediately
started hoarding up as much as I could i
order three boxes of hagoromo and kept
in my office and used it very sparingly
I should have bought more but I have
friends that bought boxes and boxes and
boxes of the stuff they might very well
be set for the rest of their career
without like 1506 that's a lot of days
for six a day I think I'm gonna make it
I have probably a ten year supply is
still at home I calculated how many
boxes what I need to last for 10 or 15
years I didn't want to become a chalk
dealer but I did like the idea that I
could be the first stick is free chalk
dealer on the block in my department I
was probably selling it regularly to
maybe eight to ten colleagues I would
reach into my cupboard in my office and
pull out another box and we do the deal
in my office that we all had a chalk fix
and we still do the original hygroma
chalk is slowly disappearing a few years
ago a Korean company bought their
formulas and did the best job of
faithfully reproducing and agreed it was
mixed emotions I was happy to know that
it would still be made but I was a
little disappointed that I was less
clever than I thought I was
in many ways mathematics is like
craftsmanship in some ways it's like
artistry in some ways it's like science
but there's a real car aft side to
giving a beautiful lecture on a
blackboard mathematicians admire this in
each other and like to use the best
tools for it there's incredible value to
this but the value isn't using it up not
hoarding it
[Music]
you
[Music]